اخبار حرب غزه من غلاف غزه اهلا بكم بعد
اتهام جنوب افريقيا لاسرائيل بارتكاب
اباده جماعيه بشكل متعمد بحق الفلسطينيين
محكمه العدل الدوليه تستمع لفريق دفاع
اسرائيل الذي طالب المحكمه رفض طلب اتخاذ
اجراءات طارئه وقال ان وقف العمليات
العسكريه في غزه سيمنع اسرائيل من الدفاع
عن نفسها وزاره الصحه في غزه تقول ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ارتكب 13 مجزره خلال
24 ساعه راح ضحيتها
151 شهيدا ومفوضي الامم المتحده لحقوق
الانسان تقول ان الوضع في جنوب القطاع
اصبح غير محتمل وتجدد مطالبتها لاسرائيل
بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار وفي الضفه الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال تشن حمله ذم واعتقال كما
ارتفع عدد الشهداء منذ بدء الحرب الى
343 والمعتقلين الى اكثر من
5800 هذا وقد قمعت قوات الاحتلال
الفلسطينيين لدى محاولتهم الوصول للمسجد
الاقصى لاداء صلاه الجمعه وعلى صعيد متصل
قصف امريكي بريطاني لمواقع جماعه انصار
الله الحوثيين في اليمن واشنطن قالت ان
القصف يهدف لتقويض قدره الجماعه على شن
هجمات في البحر الاحمر وجماعه الحوثي تعلن
مقتل خمسه اصابه سته من قواتها المسلحه
وتقول ان كل المصالح الامريكيه
والبريطانيه اصبحت اهدافا مشروعه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء